c'est une première dans la région le
nouveau préfet du poitou charentes et de
la vienne est une femme elisabeth bornes
c'est son nom a pris officiellement ses
fonctions ce matin âgé de 52 ans elle
était depuis 2008 directrice générale de
l'urbanisme à la mairie de paris fabrice
bidault et stéphane beaurain nous la
présente une femme dans l'uniforme de
préfète de la région poitou charentes
c'est une grande première elisabeth
borne est aussi la seule femme en france
métropolitaine à occuper cette fonction
et pourtant elle fait aujourd'hui c'est
tout premiers pas dans le corps
préfectoral
polytechnicienne également diplômé de la
prestigieuse école des ponts et
chaussées elle a passé plusieurs années
dans les cabinets ministériels du
pouvoir socialiste comme conseiller
technique elle est restée cinq ans à
matignon près de lionel jospin en charge
de l'urbanisme et les transports et
depuis 2008 elle était aux côtés de
bertrand delanoë comme directrice
générale de l'urbanisme à la mairie de
paris
j'ai fait une partie mon parcours dans
des cabinets ministériels j'en ai fait
une autre en administration centrale
dans des entreprises publiques et par
définition dont un préfet n'est pas
proche d'un parti un préfet est un
fonctionnaire de la république
mais elisabeth bornes connais bien aussi
le dossier ferroviaire de 2002 à 2007
elle était directrice de la stratégie à
la sncf elle a d'ailleurs raté de peu en
décembre dernier la présidence de réseau
ferré de france elle sera donc bien
placé pour suivre le chantier de la lgv
effectivement c'est un dossier que je
connais bien je connais des enjeux de
transport et les enjeux ferroviaire en
particulier ont le dossier quand même
maintenant bien avancée mais l'état
garde une responsabilité pour que toutes
les autorisations soient délivrés en
temps et en heure et le chantier se
déroule dans les meilleures conditions
donc c'est bien sûr quelque chose que je
regarderai près autre dossier
prioritaire pour la nouvelle préfète
l'emploi et la mise en place des
contrats d'avenir la sécurité la
question de l'eau est l'avenir du marais
poitevin
[Musique]